(soft music)
- Did you see him?
- I saw a oneness, a unity of things,
I was a plant and an ant
- No, but did you see him?
- I saw that there is
love and we are all a part
of that love like that, you mean?
- No an old man with a beard
and he shimmies.
And when he speaks his
voice booms, like thunder.
- I didn't see that, I saw shining light.
- Yes an old man and his
heart pours forth light.
- No, just light.
But I saw love.
And I see your love for God.
And for me, which I never saw before
and I have disrespected it.
- Perhaps we are each guilty of that.
- We are fighters.
- Perhaps that hides the
truth of us both at times.
- They love God, my people,
you showed me that, thank you.
But their thinking
should not be controlled
by these ancient terrors.
There's a modern world Archie,
your church could be part of it.
- God wants me to serve you,
it's strange and at times inexplicable.
- Together, we would be formidable,
we could be the grit that
makes the pearl for each other.
And I need you, you know them
and you truly love them.
I will not kill you.
- You have seen the
light, even if not God.
- Now, how do we get
rid of this crocodile?
You must've had a plan.
- I had faith God would
provide one when the time came.
- Not really a plan though, is it?